11 de noviembre de 1918 miles de
británicos celebran en las calles de
Londres
[Música]
tras más de 4 años de violencia finaliza
en Europa la que hasta ese momento sería
denominada la gran guerra la fecha marcó
La rendición alemana y el final de Los
imperios austrohúngaros Turco otomano y
Ruso cuatro años atrás el 28 de junio de
1914 el único heredero del imperio
austrohúngaro y su esposa fueron
asesinados en las calles de sarajevo
llevando de esta manera a Europa a un
conflicto marcado por la guerra en las
trincheras Durante los años que duró la
lucha se recuerdan especialmente las
batallas de Sony Verdún crudos
enfrentamientos donde murieron cientos
de miles de soldados en unos pocos días
también destacaría La tregua de Navidad
un hecho en el que los rivales alemanes
y británicos Se tomaron Una pausa y
compartieron durante la noche del 24 de
diciembre de 1914
la paz se firmó con el tratado de
Versalles de 1919 Alemania tuvo que
entregar territorios armas y pagar
exorbitantes sumas de dinero a los
países afectados el sometimiento de los
alemanes para muchos fue considerado una
humillación aspecto que desencadenó la
llegada de Hitler al poder en los años
30 la semilla de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial había sido sembrada